I'm Lawrence from chainsaw some games
we're here at vacci showing after char
after pleasure nationals yes
all right so after charge the three
versus three competitive game in which
one side is invisible and the other side
is invincible
I got you into the hole we do take its
parish into an overwatch for a couple of
things but not the gameplay it's very
different
Oh drop the game
I like this
like no charge
it's not a dirty
this guy's yes for free updates with
purchased again now that's not that rare
Oh scare me
no one stay close that's you
we see the shop down the got
no energy
they're up there up there
[Music]
yeah I know
and
- find into those trust drawers platform
flat beeping all right yeah yeah
absolutely we need to do that as a small
studio with a small marketing budget
it's always a risk to launch a
multiplayer only game you not want
people to declare to game dead on launch
so we need to I've them want to come
back the combined power
[Music]
okay that's so weird
danger
the realm of the lowest
yes yeah they're all day they will never
have the Polish like nine now is
oh it's nothing they're not able to do
it we know that it's technically
possible it's that not it's not in their
policy not so we have a really good
relationship with Playstation shut up
selling yeah they're just you just know
that this is something that we really
want to keep got that nun cross-platform
which is bought one okay so that's mine
PlayStation is not out of the plan it's
just not not by the airline tracks
because we need that cross absolutely
but what's cool what you said what I
like is that out at notes we have three
platforms yeah to actually cross level
and the access cool
and again
you
what am i doing what am oh yeah
right now the game is alpha we should be
hitting better around made of summer
missile and launch should be end of
something lighter but nothing is set in
stone we still have to pass traditional
console it could be a process that could
take long but it's definitely coming out
before the end of the year that is going
to decide
yeah that's what we're aiming for since
we have crossbones we kind of need to
combine the power of these three
platforms on the same day zenyk what aim
before but we have actually never
released a game on switch before so we
don't know if the process could be
longer than expected so if one likes
behind it's going to be the attendance
which because we're not used to that but
we've released given games of an Xbox
one before and on PC so there should be
no issue for Santana's release
after charlie
it's been fun
you